special edition of pft pm which by the
way debuts on peacock in september for
now it's the old-fashioned way video on
pft audio on podcast joining us today
the brand new president of the
washington football team he is former
nfl player but now anything but a player
anything but a guy on the football side
of the operation is in charge of the
business side of the operation as the
president of the team jason wright jason
it's great to talk to you how are you
pal well it's a pleasure to be on and
i'm glad you already got that clear
message that's good oh okay hey i know
you've been out and making the media
rounds and i've been doing my homework
and that's the one message it comes
through and you know it's odd to me
for a guy who was a player
to be back in
as
somebody who has no role on the football
side it reminds me almost of the pat
sumrall frank gifford guy who gets into
broadcasting and becomes a play-by-play
announcer
not a keller commentator which is
typically the job of the former player
the new frontier all together
congratulations on it and it's great to
talk to you well you know i if you if
you talk to you know my former coaches
and teammates and then you talk to folks
i worked with in business they'd
probably say like yeah put jason on the
business side
put jason on the business side of things
with relative with relative capabilities
but um no i'm excited um
to be a part of the team at what i you
know describe as a unique moment where
you know the ownership
has both in word and deed dan and tanya
in word indeed have indicated a new
direction and that new direction really
aligns with my values
and my vision for what a healthy
organization looks like so you know i'm
really excited to jump in well and
what's amazing about this jason you know
i've been in this business 20 years now
you generally are aware of the universe
of people who are looking to get certain
jobs who are angling for certain
positions especially the former players
there aren't a lot of things that a
former player can do in football and
it's typically coaching front office
agents
right
you rarely see a former player aspire to
be
in a football operation only in a
business capacity and i think a lot of
us were stunned by it um how long have
has this even been on your radar screen
that it's something you wanted to do
yeah i can talk from my personal
aspirations this this materialized a bit
miraculously for me frankly it wasn't
what i was angling towards um i was
really happy as a partner at my firm i
felt like i had a great platform to do
research on the things i cared about
serve the type of companies that excited
me and counsel ceos the way i wanted to
but this was a unique moment where my
identity as a football player from seven
years old
all the way through to the nfl and being
a team captain combined with my analytic
mind and serving businesses over time
came together in a unique way um and it
just popped up
but for me like just to give a little
insight um i don't tend to have a
machiavellian plan
about the roles that i'll have or where
i'll be i'm not building a kingdom um
i'm a bit of a nerd i'm driven by my
intellectual curiosity and i'm attracted
to big challenges um and big challenges
within organizations that have real
impact
across society and in the place where
they're located and this absolutely hits
all those criteria for me and that's
what makes this even more unusual from
my perspective most of the people who
are in the big jobs in the nfl
wanted those big jobs aspired to those
big jobs and did everything they could
to get them it sounds like you're just
minding your own business opportunity
knocks and you decided to answer yeah i
mean that's a bit of it you know um i
i'm grateful that all the tools and the
preparation were there
for me along the way um there's a lot
i'm gonna learn still too though you
know let's be clear about that um but
yeah it did it did materialize and and
in one sense um uh i'm excited about
that i'm excited about that that i
haven't been ruminating on this for
years because i think coming to it with
a set of fresh eyes
a set of unique capabilities and things
in my toolkit that might not be brought
if i were thinking about this for a long
time or brought up in the front office
is what's going to catalyze new ideas
and new innovation on the business side
and then you know i'll be held in bounds
and anchored by the great expertise that
we already have on the team so now i'm
looking forward to that sort of
catalytic combination now that you're in
the position jason do you have a
timetable in mind a rough deadline in
mind for getting the organization
to where you think it needs to be how
long of a task is that you know um it's
hard to tell because i don't start till
monday right so i've got outside in
information just like you i just got my
email well i'll get my email up and
running soon right um uh but uh
depending on where we're at
um we're depending where we're actually
at um it it's to be determined how
quickly we get to the the finish line
but i know the type of culture we want
to set
and i know the type of things that we
want to aspire to do um and i've shared
this before but the culture is one
that's rooted in principles like
inclusion and transparency openness
accountability um and you know we're in
the middle of an an independent
investigation that's going to tell us a
lot about where we're at on sexual
harassment um and the and the the work
environment that we're creating around
our colleagues
i'm going to find out a lot about where
we are in innovation around fan
engagement the fan experience where we
are in thinking about a new stadium
these are all big priorities um that
that will reshape who we are as an
institution and as a club um but
i know where we're gonna get to um we're
going to get to being highly innovative
uh integrating great technologies being
the best in fan engagement with a great
fan base that already exists
um we'll find out pretty soon how long
it is but i have 100 day plan in my head
but we ain't we're not going to be there
in 100 days
i'll tell you that much
is this a situation where
at some point if you get the
organization to where you think it needs
to be
you simply say and i hate to say this
you haven't even started yet but i
almost feel like there's a chance you
get to the point where the organization
is exactly where it needs to be you say
hey my work here is done it's on to my
next challenge or is this something that
you intend to stick with even after you
get it to where you want it to be what i
will say is i am very grateful for the
confidence
and the
and from your mouth to god's ears that
we will be there exactly where i want us
to be um i think in a little bit of the
way i think about this is uh you know
i'm i'm in this for a longer term
commitment
because i see several echelons to the
organization i keep a little bit in the
back of my mind because i don't know
what i don't know yet
um but there are so many ways that this
organization can evolve into something
an entity of greater and greater impact
there's a there's a get things right now
piece there's an establish a new
identity um that involves the name and
the brand but it's so much bigger than
that there's a redesigned fan experience
that you know incorporates all the cool
things that are happening around us in
this this rapid evolution into a more
digital future that covet has actually
brought on there's a new stadium and a
complex all that is like stuff that's in
view but there are things even beyond
that
of thinking about how we we might be a
real anchor institution in the dmv what
we do for the broader community um you
know how uh life in the dmv area can
center more around the franchise and
what we've become um for various aspects
of the community there's so many things
in my head of where this could go um
i'm not looking for an exit door i'll
tell you that much and you've made it
clear that you will be reporting
directly to owner daniel schneider ron
rivera the head coach reporting directly
to owner daniel schneider
when did you first meet daniel snyder
yeah um gosh people keep asking this i
really should like write down the
timeline my wife is the one who
remembers stuff like this i should ask
her um but it's it's fairly recent you
know it's uh you know since the since
the name was rescinded is after that in
fact i remember i was reading all that
news before our networks crossed
and our networks crossed and we started
this series of conversations
that i've i've been describing as
surprising
um you know conversations that were
eventually we talked about business and
stuff like that like i'm sharing with
you now but
they're initially rooted in values um
like the words i shared inclusion
transparency etc uh and they were really
open like you know sharing really
vulnerable stories
of mistakes that we had each
individually made in past business
decisions and in life how we gained
wisdom from that hopefully uh how we
gain wisdom from that and how that
shaped how we're thinking about things
now for the club and um you know it was
a really rapid process but very in-depth
we spent a whole lot of time together
myself dan and tanya and even coach
rivera and at the end of that we all
felt super aligned and very excited
about working together
and i i
asked that question about how long
you've actually known daniel snyder
because
there will be people who look at the
last 21 years who look at the culture
that has been in place
under the leadership and ownership of
daniel snyder and say and i have to be
blind i have to be candid this is what
people will say
he's the problem he's the common link
he's the reason why the organization is
the way it is
how much of that do you
i don't want to say do you think is true
but how much of that talk are you aware
of
and how did you personally come to the
conclusion that he is someone you want
to work with and that you believe he
genuinely is looking
to have a different organization than
what it's been over the past two decades
yeah and i'll give you three three ways
that i approach that uh the first is
in conversations like this and meeting
new folks especially that you're going
to work closely with
i tend to be um
quick to listen and a bit slow to speak
and and in listening you learn a ton
about somebody the way they think their
core values and and i've outlined you
know over the series of those
conversations
um what came out in conversations with
dan and tanya um were things that really
resonated with me that hit my core uh
that were you know in a way surprisingly
aligned with how i see the world and how
i see the club and how is he the role
football in society frankly
secondarily i am not shy about asking
very straightforward questions
um i ask them dispassionately there's no
judgment on answers
and
and actually uh dan and tanya are quite
similar
they asked me very direct questions um
and uh and that was great as well and i
also asked uh to talk to people who knew
them really well
and who didn't actually have necessarily
any equities uh uh in uh no dog in the
fight so to speak and i got to know
people that knew them really well and i
asked
targeted poignant questions there too
um and so can you ever be certain um can
they be certain about me 100 no can i be
100 certain about them nope but we sure
as hell feel certain about starting this
journey together um and
and i'm excited about it there's nothing
but positivity in my mind
now from daniel snyder's perspective as
it relates to being in the organization
during this turnaround how often do you
think he'll actually be there
sleeves rolled up working or will it be
you who's in the organization day in and
day out as the primary business employee
to complement ron rivera is the primary
football employee it's certainly the
latter you know uh it's ron's show on
the football side it's my show on the
business side it's super clear between
the two of us
super clear to dan and tanya um we've
been given that autonomy um and i think
you've actually seen that play out on
the football side if you want evidence
um the way that the draft went down the
way that the team has been assembled the
decisions that have been made on the
team side coach reveres made those right
um and so you know all i can take is the
evidence at hand so i expect it to be
exactly the same and that's what we're
all agreed on uh that said um you know
dan isn't one of these billionaires that
inherited a bunch of money let's be
clear it's a smart guy
and as we've talked i've gotten to know
the areas where he has particularly good
expertise and passion
and to say you don't want him engaged on
those topics is foolish it's foolish i
want that man's brain on those topics
it's going to make us a better franchise
it's going to expand our value it's
going to make us more creative in the
way that we operate and so
um you know he's not going to be just
you know sitting in his house seeing how
things go but most certainly the way in
which they are engaged on either side of
the organization is up to me and coach
rivera
as you've gotten to know him
have you come to the conclusion that you
know the things that are out there from
a reputational standpoint that he's
misunderstood
that he has grown and evolved past
whatever may have happened
in the past
or uh it just was flat out wrong it's
just that's just not the way he is that
the reputation isn't warranted yeah i'm
probably not grounded enough in the
external reputation and frankly i don't
necessarily want to be
um you know i i don't know i mean you've
been you've been in you know a high
media spotlight for some time
um you know i was in the league for a
long time i remember acutely
that the impression that was often out
there externally could be quite
different than what actually existed we
used to say in the locker room in the
family for you in the in the
broadcasting community it's probably
quite similar um and so i actually try
not to anchor myself in that i don't
ignore it but i try not to anchor myself
in that um you know one of my principles
as a leader in general is to be fact
based i'm going to take in
the facts um and uh you know outside in
three people removed opinions don't tend
to be particularly fact-based um and so
you know
uh i'm gonna learn for myself i think
put it that way now you're stepping into
a situation jason where there's a
certain amount of palace intrigue it has
nothing to do with the football team but
depending upon how it goes it could
affect in some way the football
operation and that is the
dynamic the reported and confirmed
multiple times over of the limited
partners the minority owners
wanting out and also this litigation
that's been playing out for the last
couple of weeks where when you read
between the lines it's pretty clear that
daniel snyder believes
possibly one or more of the minority
owners behind trying to get some
negative information out there
maybe in an effort to bring him down and
force him to sell you're going to find
yourself in the middle of that what is
your role going to be as it relates to
whatever it is that may be going on
between the majority owner and the
minority owners yeah this is a really
good and actually really complex
question i'm glad you raised it and the
way you race it actually is unique to
how i've heard it before so let me
disaggregate it
and maybe it's oversimplified but this
is how i've been thinking about it mike
there are two aspects to this there is
uh the existing allegations around
sexual harassment which are to be taken
seriously and i'm very happy about the
first step that the snyders took to
bring in an independent investigator
as i said before you know i'll find out
if it's better or worse than i perceive
it to be outside in based on public
information but that's actually
something that i know well
i've helped other organizations move
through this and depending on what the
facts are i know the three to four paths
to getting this right
um and so that's one that while it is
big and serious
and maybe messy depending on what it
actually is i know how to steer us there
and i know the culture will have on the
other side around that issue that's
clear
the one that is more nebulous and i
think a bit more removed from me and my
role is whatever is going on with the
ownership and in that one i have a very
simplified view
that no matter what is going on and i'm
not sure that i actually need to know
exactly what's going whatever is going
on
if me and the business side of the house
are focused on expanding the value of
the franchise
engaging fans getting our culture right
engaging fans substantively and
frequently
redesigning the fan experience getting
this new identity in place that's going
to drive value doing this stadium in a
both operationally efficient and
aspirational and revenue generating sort
of way if we grow the pie
that does nothing but help whatever is
going on that does nothing but help
everybody will be slightly happier in
whatever is going on if we expand the
value of the franchise and so that's one
where it is not within my control and so
i'm going to do what i did in football
and that's controlled you can control
and i'm going to be laser focused on
what my role is and i think that's a
great explanation jason but there's a
flip side to it
if in your role you're monitoring you're
aware of you're learning things about
this
separate issue however it plays out and
you get to a point where
you conclude
subjective uh subjectively excuse me uh
and authentically that it's affecting
your job that it's affecting your
ability to make the franchise as good as
it can be do you feel like you'll be
able and i know this is a hypothetical
on type number yeah
hey we need to drop this lawsuit hey we
need to make this go away we need to
find somebody else to come in and buy
these shares i mean how much of that
will be within your purview
to say the existence of this thing this
squabble this fight is keeping me from
doing my job the right way yeah i mean i
i feel like they're my brother there are
enough near-term things to tackle
for me to be wargaming before i start
wargaming the you know hypotheticals
down multiple paths there are so many of
those um but you know i want to i'll
take your question
in earnest but you know what i'm saying
though no no no no i know what you're
saying brother i know what you're saying
so so i think the
the thing that the only thing i can say
about that now because again i'm super
fact based and it's hard for me to
dimensionalize that in a fact-based way
what i say is i know i have an open
channel with
dan and tanya
i expect to establish good communication
channels with the rest of the ownership
i have a great open channel of
communication with coach rivera
and if open channels of communication
are in place if people understand and
recognize my agenda-less intent
within those open channels then i expect
everything will sort itself out but you
know it's tempting to move into the
hypotheticals it is very soap
opera-esque
i'm gonna resist and i'm going to focus
on the things we need to do now which
you know there's enough on the plate
well i have another hypothetical for you
and then i'll let you go and i
appreciate so much of your time today
the way that the things happened with
the name change initially the decision
to change the name once the new name is
determined and then the decision to go
with washington football team is the
placeholder for some undetermined period
of time until the new name can be
selected i got a theory okay and and and
i i feel like it's working the name is
working the uniforms are awesome
my theory is this if the team does well
this year that name's not going away
anytime soon that's a more limited and
narrow hypothetical but can you see a
set of facts where
the end result is you know what we're
good with washington football team we're
good with this look we're going to ride
it out for a few more years yeah i mean
all things all things are on the table
and i think that's perfectly fair that's
actually you know again to your point a
much more narrow hypothesis and fair
like it could absolutely go that path
but i think uh along that way we're
going to be engaging fans substantively
we're going to be engaging players
substantively sponsors the staff
and and frankly and i don't have it
quite in my head yet i know our
marketing team has thought through this
much more than me given up you know in
day negative four or whatever it is um
but
engaging the dmv the leaders and
influencers in the dmv community more
broadly are going to have input on that
as well but yeah that could absolutely
be the pace i mean you know it's a
little bit into into me that people will
find out a lot and you'll follow if you
if you actually scroll my twitter you'll
see that i'm quite the uh european
football fan
uh in the background and that's that's a
perfectly fine name right in that in
that world it's a perfectly fine name in
that world so it's not anathema to me
but it's not going to be my decision by
any means it's going to be a
community-based decision and we'll see
where we land
well it's amazing where things are you
know just a few weeks ago i feel like
the organization was in one of the
lowest points that any nfl team has been
in in recent years and just something
happened the bottom was struck
and the digging process began quickly
and earnestly
and here we are and uh i applaud you on
number one getting the job number two
wanting the job and i wish you all the
best going forward i hope we can have a
clear line of communication yeah it'd be
interesting to what happened you know
this is a crazy upside down year like
1982 and like 1987 we know what happened
one of those seasons for the washington
football team so i you know i i can i
just have a sense good things are coming
and your uh arrival is just another
piece of that puzzle and we wish you all
the best and we hope to talk to you down
the road thank you my good vibes well
received my brother thank you all right
take care all right all right that's
jason wright this is pft pm we'll be
back with another episode remember
coming september every weekday on
peacock we'll see you all again real
soon
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports